Francia es el país en el que nació la extrema
derecha tal y como la entendemos hoy en día.
Antes de que estallará la crisis financiera internacional,
mucho antes de que Donald Trump llegara a
ser presidente de Estados Unidos, antes, incluso,
del Brexit o de esa oleada de nacionalismo que
azota Europa… Mucho antes de todo eso, Francia
ya contaba con su propio partido de extrema derecha,
el Frente Nacional, con posibilidades reales
de ganar las elecciones.
Es más, fue en el año  2002
cuando el resto de partidos, tanto de centro
izquierda como de centro derecha, tuvieron
que unir sus fuerzas para evitar que Jean Marie
Le Pen ganará las elecciones a la presidencia.
Y justo este mes, abril de 2017, los franceses
van a volver a las urnas y no son pocos los
que piensan que esta va a ser la ocasión
definitiva. El momento en el que la extrema
derecha, con Marine Le Pen a la cabeza, conseguirá
hacerse con la presidencia francesa de una
vez por todas.
Si esto fuera así, la propia Marine Le Pen,
ya ha prometido que hará todo cuanto esté en su mano para sacar
a su Francia de la Unión Europea ¡Pero no
sólo eso!
Un triunfo de la extrema derecha en Francia supondría
toda una victoria moral para el resto de partidos xenófobos en todo del Mundo.
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque ahora la
pregunta es ¿realmente tiene Marine Le Pen
posibilidades REALES de ganar la Presidencia?
¿Quién puede pararla en su carrera hacia
el Eliseo? Hoy vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas. Y vamos a contaros la historia
de la extrema derecha francesa: una historia
que incluye luchas familiares, choques de
ego y… ¡Hasta Conejitas de PlayBoy! ¡Vamos
con ello!
La extrema derecha francesa tiene dos abuelos
ideológicos: Hitler y la OAS. Tal cual
como lo oís. Como sabéis, durante la II
Guerra Mundial, los alemanes invadieron el
Norte de Francia.
Pero el Sur, esa llamada
“Zona libre”, cuya capital era la ciudad
de VICHY, estaba gobernada por políticos
franceses afines al Partido Nacional Socialista
Alemán. Cuando termina la guerra, el nuevo
presidente galo, el General Charles de Gaulle,
ejecuta a los principales dirigentes del Gobierno
de Vichy  ¡Pero esperad
un momento! Porque todavía quedaba muchísima
gente que había apoyado a este gobierno colaboracionista.
Es decir, que todavía quedaba muchísima gente que aunque no tuviera poder político,
apoyaba y defendía esta ideología.
¡Y, ojo, porque muchos de ellos estaban en
el ejército!
Años más tarde, concretamente en 1961, Francia
permite que su colonia más preciada, Argelia,
celebre un referendum de autodeterminación.
Y como os podéis imaginar, esto no sentó nada bien
a todos esos sectores de extrema derecha
que estaban dentro del ejército francés.
Así es como nace la OAS, una organización
terrorista cuyo principal objetivo es acabar con los
independentistas argelinos.
No somos terroristas, somos patriotas.
Estamos en deuda con los soldados que murieron luchando en Argelia,
y con los 3 millones de ciudadanos franceses que viven allí.
En 1962, Argelia se convierte en un estado
independiente. Y los miembros de la OAS intentan
acabar con el propio De Gaulle en varias ocasiones
porque lo consideran un traidor a la patria.
Por suerte, en 1965, la policía francesa
desmantela los últimos comandos ¡Pero esperad
un momento! Porque aquí no termina la historia.
Al igual que ocurrió al final de la II Guerra
Mundial, acabar con los cabecillas de un movimiento
no significa que no quedara gente que los
apoyara y que compartiera las mismas ideas.
Francia, el país de la libertad, la igualdad
y la fraternidad, es también el hogar de muchísimos sectores sociales que odian a los argelinos
e incluso añoran el III Reich. Y
esos son los mimbres que utilizó JEAN MARIE
LE PEN para fundar, 10 años más tarde, el
Frente Nacional.
“Es la prensa la que habla todo el día
de la guerra, la persecución de los judíos,
los excesos de la ocupación… permanentemente,
la radio, la televisión…”
Los comienzos no fueron cosa fácil. Durante
los años 70, el Frente Nacional no subía
del 5% de los votos. Y el propio Le Pen sufrió
un atentado en su propia casa ¡Pero esperad
un momento porque aquí llega la parte divertida
de la historia! En 1977, la familia Le Pen
hereda de un empresario francés afín al
partido, nada menos que un PALACIO.
El Palacio de MONTRETUT, que en seguida se convierte
en la sede no-oficial del Frente Nacional,
o lo que es lo mismo, la familia Le Pen.
Porque, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
en este partido político todo queda en familia.
Desde la mansión Montretut, Jean Marie organizaba
todas sus campañas electorales que le llevaron
a convertirse en la tercera fuerza política
a finales de los 80. Mientras tanto, su hija
Marine Le Pen, le seguía en sus quehaceres
diarios y aprendía los secretos del arte
de la política profesional, para convertirse en la lideresa
que es ahora.
Más tarde, se le uniría su
nieta, Marion Marenchal Le Pen, que a día
de hoy es diputada por el Frente Nacional
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque aunque este partido
se presente como el campeón de los valores
familiares… la familia Le Pen no está tan
unida como parece. Y sí, ya sé que en VisualPolitik
nunca hablamos de cotilleos ni de la vida
privada de nadie… ¡Pero en este caso es
necesario para entender la vida política
de este partido!
Como os decía, en los años 80, Jean Marie
Le Pen, que a partir de ahora le vamos a llamar
Le Pen padre, estaba on fire. Cada elección
sacaba más votos que la anterior.
Y en ese momento es cuando
decide contratar a un escritor para que le
escriba su biografía. Y, por supuesto, le
ofrece acomodo en su propia mansión, en este palacio Montretut.
Y os
preguntaréis ¿Qué hizo este escritor? Pues
nada menos que seducir a la mujer de Le Pen
Padre. Tal cual como lo oís. No sólo eso,
los dos amantes huyeron de la mansión, abandonaron a Jean Marie Le Pen
y meses más tarde la señora Le Pen aparece
en la portada de la revista PLAYBOY. Así
es como el mundo entero descubrió el lado
más sensual de la extrema derecha.
Como os podéis imaginar, todo esto supuso un auténtico cisma en el clan Le Pen. Así que no importaba que el
padre subiera en votos, su hija cada vez estaba
más distante.
Pero el auténtico punto de inflexión de
este clan Le Pen llegó en el año
2002. En ese año, Francia celebró unas elecciones
presidenciales.
Y por primera vez en la historia,
Le Pen pasó a la segunda vuelta.
Como ya sabéis, el sistema electoral francés
tiene dos vueltas. Es decir, que cuando van
a elegir presidente, primero hacen unas elecciones
a las que se presentan todos los candidatos
al Eliseo, 3, 4, 5, los que sean… Después
de esta votación, hacen una segunda en la
que sólo se presentan los dos candidatos
que más votos sacaron en la primera.
Pues bien, en este año 2002 los dos candidatos que consiguieron pasar a la segunda vuelta fueron Jacques Chirac
de centro-derecha, y Le Pen padre, de la extrema derecha.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cómo es posible que
ganaran las elecciones dos candidatos de derechas?
¿Acaso no hay partidos de izquierda en Francia?
Lo cierto es que durante todos estos años,
los Le Pen aprendieron una importante lección
en política: los votos cautivos no existen.
Así que aunque el Frente Nacional sea un
partido de extrema derecha, su programa electoral
incluye propuestas muy atractivas para los
sindicalistas
y todos aquellos que viven en zonas industriales.
No olvidéis que Le Pen defiende el proteccionismo
no sólo para las empresas francesas sino
también para los TRABAJADORES franceses.
¿Os suena eso de “Los americanos primero? Pues
no es un invento de Trump. Eso ya lo decía
Jean Marie Le Pen en los 90, pero con los
franceses. Así que en 2002, las principales
ciudades industriales como Marsella, que tradicionalmente
habían votado a partidos de izquierda, se
volcaron con el Frente Nacional.
Y por eso, en esta segunda vuelta, los votantes
que se mantenían fieles al partido socialista francés tuvieron que tragarse su orgullo y votar a
un candidato de centro-derecha. Cualquier
cosa era buena con tal de evitar el ascenso
de un político filonazi y xenófobo como Le Pen.
Y así es como el clan Le Pen aprendió una
segunda lección en política: no sólo hay
que caerle bien a tu votante sino que tampoco
puedes asustar demasiado a los demás.
De lo contrario, pueden formar un frente común
contra ti y evitar que llegues a gobernar.
La navidad dejó de ser dulce en MONTRETUT
a partir de 2002. Marine Le Pen comenzó su
campaña interna en contra de su propio padre.
No olvidéis que Jean Marie es un político
que se presenta a las elecciones con perlas
como esta:
“Tiene que haber una autoridad y pensamos
que en una casa, el más cualificado para
ejercer esa autoridad es el hombre” –Jean
Marie Le Pen (Le droit ajourd´hui, 1979).
Marine Le Pen, sin embargo, era una mujer
dispuesta a ejercer su autoridad política para
limpiar la imagen de un partido que haría
que hasta Windows 95 parezca algo moderno.
A diferencia de su padre, Marine está en
contra de la pena de muerte y a favor de la
unión de parejas homosexuales. Todo esto
son cosas que incluso los votantes de Frente
Nacional aprecian. Y por eso, en 2011, Le
Pen hija sucedió al padre como presidenta
del partido.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque las cosas
nunca fueron fáciles!
“Me pregunto qué le motiva a Marine y a
sus diputados para haber lanzado esta campaña
contra mi”.
Lo cierto es que cuando has sido el líder
y fundador de la extrema derecha francesa
durante la friolera de 39 años, es difícil
aceptar que tu hija te de órdenes.
Así que a día de hoy, Jean Marie Le Pen
es el presidente honorario del Frente Nacional…
pero vota por libre en el parlamento europeo
“Hize campaña por JEAN MARIE LE PEN, no
por MARINE LE PEN… y gané por el 33%”
¿Y adivináis quién es su principal apoyo
dentro del partido? ¡Efectivamente! SU NIETA,
Marion Le Pen, quien a su vez está empezando
su pequeña guerra interna contra su tía
Marine.
“El es un provocador, un anticonformista,
y eso no es siempre bonito de escuchar”
Mientras tanto, la moderación de Marine en
combinación con la salida de la crisis en
Francia está funcionando mucho mejor que
las estrategias electorales de su padre.
Conozco África y considero que Europa ha cometido un error en el pasado.
Debería haber establecido relaciones de cooperación, de desarrollo económico con África, porque creo
que es una de las maneras de fijar a las poblaciones en su países de origen.
De hecho, los
últimos sondeos para estas elecciones de
2017 le dan cerca de un 25% de intención
de voto, lo que la coloca entre la primera
y la segunda candidata mejor valorada. En
unas elecciones donde hay 5 candidatos, todos
ellos con peso específico, un 25% es un auténtico
triunfo. Y es casi seguro que Le Pen pasará
a la segunda vuelta.
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque ser menos
radical que su padre no significa que Marine
Le Pen sea, ni mucho menos, una candidata
moderada. En esos famosos 144 puntos de los
que consta su programa electoral, Le Pen hija
defiende el cierre de fronteras, la deportación
de inmigrantes, la salida del euro y, por supuesto,  la vuelta al Franco francés.
Pero esperad un momento! Porque lo que ahora
os estaréis preguntando es ¿Realmente puede
Le Pen ser la nueva presidenta de Francia?
Vamos a verlo!
Durante años, el centro-derecha francés
veía cómo los Le Pen podrían comerse a
su electorado. Es cierto que buena parte de
los votos del Frente Nacional viene de los
caladeros tradicionales de los partidos socialistas.
Pero, en época de crisis, los discursos de
los valores familiares y en contra de los
inmigrantes pueden ser muy atractivos para
los votantes conservadores.
Así que en 2016, el gran partido del centro-derecha
francés, LOS REPUBLICANOS, eligieron a un
candidato que incorporaba todas esas propuestas
tan típicas de los Le Pen. Ese hombre es
Fransuá Fillón.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Está funcionando esta
estrategia de acercamiento al Frente Nacional?
Pues parece que no. Desde que Fillón es candidato,
los Republicanos no han hecho más que caer
en las encuestas de intención de voto y ahora
está compitiendo por el tercer puesto con
el candidato de la extrema izquierda, Jean-Luc
Melenchon.
Los escándalos sexuales y de de corrupción,  y el hecho
de que los votantes prefieren siempre el original
a la copia han sumido al centro-derecha francés
en el olvido.
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque la batalla
no ha terminado. Aún queda un hombre dispuesto
a frenar el huracán Le Pen. Su nombre es
EMMANUEL MACRON y viene de ser el Ministro
de Economía del gobierno socialdemócrata
de Manuel Valls.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Es entonces Macron un socialdemócrata?
¡Pues no! Macron se ha presentado a las elecciones
por su cuenta, como un candidato independiente.
Es más, el mismo Manuel Valls, que le eligió
ministro, no le ha prestado su apoyo hasta
finales de marzo ¡Y no olvidéis que las
elecciones son en Abril!
¿Y qué defiende Emmanuel Macron? Pues básicamente,
lo contrario que Le Pen. Macron quiere acabar
con todos los privilegios de los que gozan
las empresas subvencionadas por el estado
y eliminar las barreras en el mercado laboral
que impiden que los jóvenes puedan encontrar
un trabajo. Por supuesto, está en contra
de discriminar a nadie por razones de raza
o religión. En materia económica, ha presentado
un programa de responsabilidad fiscal para
reducir el déficit público. Y por si todo
esto fuera poco, una de sus propuestas consiste
en prohibir a los altos cargos que enchufen
a sus familiares en la administración pública.
Vamos, que es la antítesis absoluta del Clan
Le Pen.
Las últimas encuestas ya le
sitúan por encima del Frente Nacional. Los
sondeos le dan más de un 25% de intención
de voto. Es decir, que pese a ser un candidato
independiente, tiene muchas probabilidades
de ser la persona que se enfrentará a Le
Pen en la segunda vuelta.
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque todavía
hay un factor decisivo en estas elecciones:
LA ABSTENCIÓN.
Por ejemplo, si en una
segunda vuelta, el Frente Nacional mantuviera
el 90% de sus votantes mientras que el otro
candidato se quedara con un 40 o 50%, tendría
muchos problemas para ganar la presidencia.
Y ¡Ojo al dato! Porque si algo caracteriza
a los partidos de extrema derecha en toda
Europa son las adhesiones incondicionales
que generan. En este otro vídeo, os hacemos
una radiografía de esa ola de populismo nacionalista
que se ha extendido por todo el continente.
No os lo perdáis y haced click aquí.
Y ahora la pregunta es ¿Conseguirá Macron
ganarle a Marine Le Pen? ¿Alguno de los otros
candidatos pegará un último repunte antes
de las elecciones? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios.
Y no olvidéis que sacamos nuevos vídeos todas las semanas,
así que suscribiros al canal si queréis estar al tanto
de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto!